17 ans enfermé dans une cellule aveugle
au cameroun alors qu'il n'avait rien à
se reprocher michel atangana est un
français que son pays a oublié brimer
maltraités il a même été privés
d'assistance consulaire pendant 12 ans
c'est pourtant un droit fondamental pour
tout ressortissant français
c'est très douloureux cgt enfermé dans
un sous sol
à la gendarmerie
dans le cellule de 7 mètres carrés
sans droits
et j'y ai passé effectivement 17
millions d'années dans les années 90
michel atangana travailler au cameroun
auprès d'entreprises françaises de
concert avec le pouvoir de paul biya
toujours président actuellement mais en
1997 il est arrêté accusé de rallier
l'opposant titus edzoa
il nie une parodie de justice le
condamne alors à une lourde peine de
prison pour détournement de fonds
publics
un groupe de travail de l'onu reconnaît
en 2013 sa condition de victimes de
détentions arbitraires
finalement il est libéré sous
l'impulsion de françois hollande en 2014
et rapatrié en france
mais michel atangana n'est toujours pas
réhabiliter tout ce qui a été fait par
le cameroun à mon endroit par la
libération ne donne un statut de
coupable et la france à garder ce statut
dont je ne peux rien faire s'ils ne peut
pas vivre ce papa travaille durant la
détention de michel atangana
les ministres des affaires étrangères
qui se sont succédé n'ont rien fait les
autorités françaises ne peuvent
interférer dans le fonctionnement de la
justice d'un pays tiers
le droit international proscrit toute
ingérence dans le fonctionnement de la
justice d'un état souverain
la france est allée dans le monde entier
mais dans mon cas il n'y a pas eu
d'intervention
en effet en 2009 par exemple bernard
kouchner n'avait pas hésité à exiger de
l'iran qu'il libère l'enseignante le
titre ice nous voulons nous exigeons
nous souhaitons même en plus au plus
vite sa libération
plusieurs fois interrogé sur cette
injustice le quai d'orsay n'a donné
aucune suite à nos questions laurent
bigot ancien diplomate ce directeur pour
l'afrique de l'ouest à l'époque dénonce
la situation michel thierry atangana
étant juste droit de se poser la
question qu'est ce qui fait que moi je
ne suis pas considéré comme un citoyen à
part entière et je ne puisse pas
bénéficier de la protection complète de
l'état français alors oui mais quand il
se pose cette question il se dit c'est
peut-être parce que j'ai la peau noire
il ya français prolongent en fait sa
faute lourde on ne répare en pas son
erreur
aujourd'hui il ya la même indifférence
qu'il y avait lorsqu'il était incarcéré
donc je pose la question où est l'état
où est l'humanité de l'état français
après eric dupond moretti
c'est aujourd'hui au tour de l'avocat
antoine v de défendre le dossier de
michel thierry atangana
on est face à un processus politique
diplomatique extrêmement bloqués et dans
lequel à mon sens michel thierry
atangana n'a pas reçu la reconnaissance
réelle de son statut est évidemment pas
les indemnisations auxquelles il a droit
mais aujourd'hui sept victimes de
détentions arbitraires se bat pour que
cette situation n'arrive pas à d'autres
il a inspiré un amendement dans le cadre
de l'actuelle réforme de la justice
adoptée à l'assemblée le 20 mai dernier
j'ai vraiment pris
conscience des absences de la france
pour certains français dont j'ai décidé
de participer un meilleur accompagnement
des français
en travaillant avec les députés d'empyr
valeur à fond pour protéger les français
entre 1500 et 2500 français sont détenus
à l'étranger dont 500 sans cause connue
et deux millions et demi de français
vivant hors de l'hexagone qui pourrait
un jour devenir comme michel atangana
les victimes d'une détention arbitraire